es ist eigentlich schon eine krasse
sache also man hat selbst ein paar
unannehmlichkeiten so weiter und so fort
aber man kann damit hatte ich in einem
menschen das leben retten
zu hause ist willkommen zu einer neuen
baby und hat jetzt bei mir klick auf
play meine tiefpunkt com ip ist glaube
ich im play titel city games laut data
communication katheter stichwort
katheder ich will auch etwas erzählen
ich habe eine relativ krasse
entscheidung getroffen
für mich und von der mich halt mal so
berichten ja nicht primär mit youtube zu
tun als könne ich kann ich beruhigen
ich habe jetzt nicht vom einen kanal zu
schließen es geht um was anderes
zwar ist voll mit der tür ins haus und
zwar hab ich mir überlegt knochenmark zu
spenden
ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr wisst was das
noch fast das bedeutet oder wann man das
macht was die eltern auch nicht
es ist auch eine relativ große
angelegenheit und deswegen erhielt mal
von erzählen und dass eventuell auch
dokumentieren die of view tier so drauf
so nebenbei vielleicht auch mal das
bewusstsein dafür zu steigern
also als aller erstes mal was warum
spende mal knochenmark das spendet man
um leuten die gewisse erkrankungen haben
beispielsweise die chemie- oder so eine
möglichkeit geben wir geben wir gesund
zu werden
möglichkeit zu geben wieder gesund zu
werden also leukämie im volksmund
blutkrebs genannt also krebs im blut der
sich zwar im ganzen körper verteilt
und ich spüre ich spende ihrem blut
stammzellen so und dann werden die diese
stammzellen wie man das eben nennt wenn
die mir jetzt dass die werden dann im
körper des empfängers der meint mein
buch dann kriegt zerstört und dann
kommen meine rein und er hat dann
sozusagen trägt meine gesunden
hoffentlich blutstammzellen mit sich
herum und kann er sich wieder gesund
werden und das gibt halt leute eine
chance wieder gesund zu werden die
eigentlich
unheilbar krank sind und deswegen will
ich das machen weil für mich ist es ja
es ist wahr eine ärgerliche sache und
das mittel was ich dafür einnehmen muss
das hat irgendwie durch nebenwirkungen
und man schmerzen oder so aber ich
persönlich kann ich damit leben retten
menschen denken ja aber ich kann nicht
viel spielen und deswegen mache ich der
ok deswegen wollte ich das lied so gut
als da ich hab einfach am laufenden band
erzählt die ganze zeit wenig runter
gefallen aber jetzt fakt dass wenn man
einmal auftreten eines schwer wieder
reinzufinden
das ist wirklich gut wo wir nicht stehen
geblieben
damit kann ich eben den leuten helfen
wieder gesund zu werden und ich will das
mal dokumentieren das liegt für mich
jetzt so aus ich weiß heute zur
voruntersuchung beck und morgen ultra
früh aufgestanden ist ich das mal geben
ich bin halt so gelitten
gestern nacht schon echt wenig
geschlafen ich mich an stelle gestern
nach schon nur fünf stunden geschlafen
und dann abhängig machen und dann heute
nacht auch noch richtig krass ich war
gestern gleich in zwei uhr wacht musste
heute um viertel vor sieben raus also
unter fünf stunden schlaf
nachdem ich gestern schon mal schön
geschlafen hat das ist für mich ganz
schlimm
ich weiß nicht wie ihr heute mit schlaf
müsst ihr viel schlafen oder wenig bis
man die kommentare reichten gibt ja
leute die schlaffe einfach so ultras
wenig warum fand ich da herunter
das so gemein gebaut wo ich bin
wahrscheinlich bin ja wo ich bin
definitiv ab weil ich menschen die runde
so schreibt was meine kommentare wird
dann bist du im schlaf
die kritiker wiesen spacken die über so
wie sein wie gesagt ich muss also wieder
reinfinden in minecraft wie so ein
fucking talkshow moderator vor der
kamera wechsel und
danke danke sind jetzt eigentlich die
dinge wo man runter fallen muss her
finde ich ok das wort träger so ja jetzt
wenn ich jetzt durch
okay okay okay wie tricky tricky googles
weiter ich habe es richtig gut gefallen
ich jetzt noch gleich zwei mal ist es
gar nicht weit bis eben was ist los
leider vergessen wie man deutsch kann
ich dahin bitte er um mein gott hier
etwas zurück was runtergelaufen gedrückt
das missfällt ich mache okay so jetzt
könnt ihr durch einmal ja für mich geht
es jetzt so weiter heute mal die
voruntersuchung am 21 wird dann
voraussichtlich die spende statt
wie gesagt ich habe vor das alles zu
dokumentieren ich werde dann fünf
stunden lang an seinem tropf nicht am
tropf gehängt sondern an so eine so eine
art dialyse oder so also da wo man blut
gefiltert wird und zentrifugiert und
regen rausgeholt werden die haben wollen
und das zu spenden weil er kann ich mein
ganzes punkt nehmen
der will nur die stammzellen daraus dann
hänge ich da ewig an der maschine und es
würde die schlimme und grausam und die
medikamente die ich davor kriege werden
wir grausame schmerzen bereiten das habe
ich mir schon gesagt es war so schlimm
heute ich war bei dieser ärztin habe mit
so einer ärztin vorgespräch geführt also
die kümmert sich echt gut um einen alles
machen das ist die dkms also die
deutsche knochenmarkspende
ich muss ja nicht überspringen oder
bitte nicht das kann man doch gar nicht
ja danke und man macht es ganz gut und
die ärzte heute so ja gut wenn sie diese
mittel nehmen die sie brauchen dann das
sind schon schmerzen und so sie fühlt
sich an als wenn sie von der dampfwalze
überfahren oder so
was ich mir jetzt auch gerade mann oh
mann das ist echt ne nummer aber ich
mache das weil ich kann halt für mich
ist es halt ein bisschen scheiß muss
dann halt mal früh aufstehen und dann da
und dahin fahren mich irgendwie
vorstellen untersuchen was ein grund
spenden pipapo und dann halt diese
medikamente nehmen mit den
nebenwirkungen ich so hieß die sind aber
das geht alles schon weil wie gesagt man
kann damit menschenleben retten und das
ist es mir wert
ihr könnt ja meine kommentare schreiben
was ihr davon haltet will dir selbst was
machen so blutspenden auch wenn es für
euch mit unannehmlichkeiten verbunden
ist also was ist für euch irgendwie dass
es euch weh tut dass ihr mal ein
bisschen was aufgeben müsste wäre es
euch das wert persönlich oder sagt hier
muss sich jeder selbst darum kümmern
andere sonst machen das würde ich auch
mal echt interessieren
das und das mit dem schlaf thema das
unsere sachen die mich heute ein
bisschen beschäftigen
das wetten dass ist eine richtige
medikation
ja wir können das hier noch kein
bisschen weiter kommt ok ich heute aber
so einen thementag ich wirklich gar
nicht
ja wie könnt ihr euch schon eine kiste
wenn ich gut an stelle aber dafür bin
ich nicht bekannt zumindest nicht in
diesen tagen die starken der minecraft
pause noch eine sache sagen und zwar
voll cool wie das video von gestern
angekommen es jetzt schon fast 3000
klicks sind werte die mir sehr gut
gefallen nicht toll da bist du schon
youtube hat stehen auf klicks und keine
ahnung gleich sind haben auch cool dass
ich das so gut gefällt ich habe auch die
damen um einen teenager ausprobiert fand
ich auch ganz witzig ich wollte das
thema noch abschließen bevor das death
matches anfängt und zwar ja wie gesagt
als ich würde euch echt bitten dass hier
noch mal eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreibt weil es ist
eigentlich eine krasse sache also man
hat selbst ein paar unannehmlichkeiten
so weiter und so fort aber man kann
damit er nicht in einen menschen das
leben retten und das finde ich über
krass dass so was geht und da bin ich
gerne dazu bereit
ich glaube das problem ist dass man da
gar nicht drauf kommt also ich wusste
davor auch nicht von dieser möglichkeit
dass es sowas gibt
ich wusste sehr wohl von den
möglichkeiten denn hierzu flossen diese
möglichkeit bewusst nicht ich bin
irgendwann auch willkommen in der uni so
eine anfangs typisierung war wo man so
abstriche gemacht hat bei mir geht es
mittlerweile schon weiter also alter wie
alter was für einen ping maxi hat auf
diesem server ach du scheiße das 2
das ist ja es ist eher so ein overpair
overnight 1000 louis kräfte wieder aus
schnee gemacht von richards erwischt
dann bei mir der universalisierung
aktionen da bin ich draufgekommen
abgesagt klar das unterstütze ich
kostet mich kaum was und einem anderen
hat sie gesagt das leben retten kann es
schon so oft gesagt aber ihr müsst ich
das mal vorstellen stellt mal vor ihr
seid vielleicht die person die jemanden
helfen können und jemanden der über die
stärke der pranke krank ist
sterbenskrank ist dann das leben retten
und er macht sich weil er nicht dafür
bist oder so das ja eigentlich auch
deswegen oder ihr könnt gar nicht machen
wo nicht nicht könnte
deswegen will ich euch dieses video auch
nutzen wir uns ein bisschen zu erzählen
was da so ist also wie gesagt dkms macht
dass ich verlinke euch auch mal die
homepage in der beschreibung und sagt
vielleicht immer dazu dass ich definitiv
jetzt hilfe überhaupt nichts bekomme ich
komme auch für die blutspende an sich
nichts ich sage dass hier einfach weiß
mir wichtig ist und weil ich finde dass
noch nicht genug leute davon bescheid
wissen darüber bescheid wissen sagt man
übrigens deutschen combo
okay die westlb hat mich was soll da von
trio alter wie keidel nicht zutritt auf
mich meine fresse
wenn ich nicht cool news kräftig
kassieren und dann alle minecraft hetzt
die jetzt schon auf der 1.8 spielt oder
sich auskennen schreibt mir nicht in die
kommentare
schreibt mir mal in die kommentare ob
man auf der 1.8 noch blockieren sollte
macht das noch sinn oder nicht weiß ich
nicht was ich aber weiß dass ich erst
mal flüchten muss leichter lektüre
zurückgesetzt schülern leben
ich hab halt nur noch ein leben wenn ich
jetzt sterbe dann war es das für mich so
du musst aber jetzt aber drauf gehen ja
okay er hat nicht die treppe hoch zuvor
ins wasser zu gehen den hof auch noch
ein leben ich habe ihn anfang der an den
fingern das ist unfassbar
das ist so unfassbar comics kann im
gesetz nicht geben das wird nicht
reichen
los los los los los los los muss man
sich aufs schiff dann habe ich den weg
vom schiff nach dem final ton strom vom
schiff ja das wird gut dass wir gut das
wird und stirbt und er ist genau da
drauf gegangen also gutes timing so
loose kräfte und die fliehkraft auch in
wunderschöner name fällt auf seiten sein
letztes leben verloren
ich würde halt nicht im wasser gegen
mich kämpfen denn ich spiele ja am kran
crafter pc und mit der krankhafter
leitung die auf meiner leitung warten
und dies einfach so ok also hier auch
playmate irrt man so einen krassen
vorteil
das glaubt ihr nicht das glaubt ihr echt
nicht auf dem wasser gesehen da war ich
will sich wirklich übertreiben also ist
es nicht so krass ey guck mal wie sie
dir geht mir auch denk mir auch jetzt
also ist es nicht aber man hat schon
gewisse vorteile
ja aber er will irgendwie nicht kämpfen
was mich kein bisschen aufgeregt ehrlich
gesagt meine fresse wie gesagt wenn du
nicht kämpfen willst dann spielt anblick
der kanzler verloren haben aber wenn die
kameras auf templates gibt es hier geht
es um gefühle wasser achtung
das wird spannend jetzt werke wer kann
es schaffen dieses das umgebende wasser
sei jetzt mal so ganz für sich zu
entscheiden
ich oder dieser alle pazifisten ja und
man bitte kämpft doch mal
jetzt kommt er raus
jetzt kommt daran wie ich das hasse
alter mein gott wie ich sowas hasse es
ist so asozial alter auch komm schon wo
ist er
dahinten okay zumindest jetzt mal die
freundlichkeit besessen mir nicht noch
weiter hinterher zu gehen aber er weiß
jetzt auch nicht wo ich bin ich mache
das nie ist es einem wirklich spiel mit
geld ja ich wünsche dir auch gut lag
mein freund ich wünsche dir auch gut lag
aber heute leute plötzlich erwischen
walter desch days.com river lustig
weiter
und jetzt jetzt wird abgerechnet jetzt
ist ja wunderbar wie üblich noch gut
abgezogen zweieinhalb herzen nicht
schlecht habe ich nur gezockt aber ist
doch sehr knackig ohne wie gesagt heute
schreibt auch um einen zwischen
angesprochenen themen in die kommentare
für mich sehr interessieren wir sehen
uns morgen wieder so weit will hier
eröffnen lassen like damit sich gefallen
hat haut rein macht's gut und liege dort
job